[MUSIC PLAYING]
NOAH FALSTEIN:
I'm Noah Falstein,
I'm Chief Game Designer at
Google, and happy to be your MC
for the day.
Welcome, everybody.
This is the Google
Developer Day at GDC 2017.
Boy, it's just amazing.
GDC has grown
literally 1,000 fold
since the first one that was
held 30 years ago in Chris
Crawford's house.
And I wasn't at that one, I've
been at every one ever since.
And the first one I went
to, the entire conference
was about a third the
size of this room.
So it's just great to
see what's happening.
So we're really happy to be
kicking it off this year.
This industry-- thank you--
and our involvement
in it has grown
because of the contributions
of developers like you.
And you may not think of
Google as a gaming company,
but the fact is our platforms,
our tools, the store support,
it's just an amazing variety
of game development efforts
that we have behind you.
And we're going to give you an
idea of just how all that stuff
works at today's event.
And I should hit the
right button here.
Sorry.
So we're going to
start off today
with our keynote speeches.
That'll include speakers
from Google Play.
And from there we're
going to launch
into a series of five
minute lightning talks
from a range of teams, so
a lot of really fun stuff
I'm looking forward
to sharing with you.
We're going to have some Q&A
with our speakers after that,
and then we have
a break for lunch.
After lunch, it's time for three
really interesting and relevant
panels that feature some
of our gaming partners.
And we're going to
start with a panel
about launching
on the Play Store.
Follow that with one about
building communities.
And finally a
discussion on lessons
learned by indie developers.
But before we jump
into all of that,
let me recap a bit about
what a memorable year
2016 has been for us.
There were some great hits
like the phenomenon that
was "Pokemon Go," and then
there were the popular games
like "Star Wars, Galaxy of
Heroes" and "Clash Royale,"
both of which were
built with novel ways
to keep users engaged
and coming back for more.
We've also had a lot
of our own launches
as well, with Google
entering the hardware space.
While Google Home makes for a
great living room assistant,
the Pixel phone
shows our commitment
to building a high quality,
beautifully designed device
inside and out.
We are really gratified to
hear CNET say just last month,
"The Google Pixel remains our
favorite phone, bar none."
Combined with Android
N's game-friendly sustain
performance mode and the
integration of the Vulcan API,
it makes for a really
formidable and useful platform
for your games.
The Pixel phone was also the
first Daydream-ready device.
And with the addition of our
very affordable Daydream View
and its controller,
players can now
immerse themselves in fun and
innovative VR experiences.
We've also released the
first Tango AR phone.
And when GDC's floor
opens on Wednesday,
you're going to be able
to try out both Daydream
and Tango at our booth there.
We're excited with the games
that we've released so far,
but we're really looking
forward and eager to play
the other great titles
that a lot of you
are working on right now.
You're also going to
hear more about the ways
that Google's teams are
supporting your games
throughout the full lifecycle.
Our Firebase tools and
infrastructures, for example,
give you access to real time
analytics, push notifications,
storage and ads across
a variety of languages.
And today we're really excited
to announce that Firebase is
completely available on
mobile for its C++ and Unity
developers at this point.
Google Cloud Platform
also makes building
multiplayer games very easy.
And when you need to scale
with a rocket ride of a game
like "Pokemon Go,"
that's very important.
By the way, the Cloud platform
has their own expo floor space
as well.
Once your game
has been launched,
our AdWords service grows
your audience directly,
using machine learning to
target players directly
in their searches.
And then the power
of YouTube kicks in,
supercharging the
growth of mobile gaming.
So all of these
and more are going
to be covered in
our lightning talks.
But none of this
would have happened
without developers like you.
We spend a lot of time
over the last year
reaching out to our developers
and the whole community,
listening to your feedback and
bringing that back in-house
to improve our
platform and tools.
So let me urge you
to continue that
by taking this opportunity
today and talking with some
of the many Googlers who
are here in the audience,
and who have been involved in
supporting game developers.
Googlers, can you raise
your hands and wave?
So we've got quite
a few up here.
People will be around
most of the day.
And please have a
chance to talk to them.
Thanks very much.
But now on to Paul, who's
our product lead for the Play
Store, to share a
bit more with you
from how we're helping
people find better games
and more engaged users.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PAUL BANKHEAD: Thanks Noah.
Hi everyone.
As Noah mentioned, I look
after the Google Play Store.
And I'm here to share
an update into how
we think about games, as well
as a sneak peek in some features
that we're developing.
I started playing games
as a kid on an 8088 PC.
But I had to be careful not
to get caught by my parents,
because they thought computers
were only for WordPerfect,
Quicken, Lotus 1-2-3.
As a teenager, I used to
sneak into my dad's office
with my friends to play
"Warcraft" and "StarCraft."
Now I know gaming's come
a long way since then
with the mobile revolution.
And I feel really
lucky to be part
of the team at Google
Play that helps
users discover great games.
Now don't worry, because my
kids, I've got four of them,
play a lot of "Minecraft" and a
lot of "Kingdom Rush" with me.
So you can rest assured
the next generation is
being raised properly.
[LAUGHTER]
Android has been the world's
largest mobile gaming platform
for a long time, and it's
still growing, especially
in emerging markets.
Last year, we added
over 300 million users
in countries like Brazil,
India, and Indonesia.
In addition to
helping you reach over
the billion-plus users
that are on Android,
we also want to help
you build your business.
So we've been adding
more forms of payment
for more users in
more countries,
and simplifying
the payment flow.
Last year, over
100 million users
gained access to a new form
of payment on Google Play.
And users in 136
countries can buy
your virtual goods and your
games on the Play platform.
I mentioned the user
growth in emerging markets,
but we're also
seeing great growth
in consumer spending in those
markets, at over 70% last year.
So there's a lot of momentum
and a lot of future growth ahead
for the ecosystem.
Now Android isn't just about
being the largest mobile gaming
platform.
We also want to deliver
the highest quality user
experience.
When we built the Pixel phone
and the Daydream VR set,
we designed the full hardware
and software stack ourselves.
And this allowed us to
focus on important details
like battery life, camera
quality, and UI consistency.
The response has been
fantastic, and we're
really proud of
the quality built
into each of the products.
And we don't just keep the
improvements for ourselves.
Android N is open source and
it's the best mobile operating
system we've ever
built. This year,
Google is still
investing heavily
in performance and
polish for Android.
And we look forward to
sharing more details with you
later this year when
we announce Android O.
The Play Store team
has been laser-focused
on improving the quality
of the user experience,
both within the store and
within the apps and games that
are downloaded from Play.
About a billion users
come to the Play Store
every month to learn
about apps and games.
And so we run hundreds
of experiments
to optimize their experience.
Optimize the store for us
has meant growing downloads
by putting the
right game in front
of the right user in
the right context.
And this is still
true, but we're
rethinking what right game
and right context means.
We don't really
think a user should
have to download 20
games before finding one
that she really likes.
And so this year, we've
begun tuning our algorithms
to optimize for user
engagement, not just downloads.
So for example, a title that
gets a whole bunch of downloads
because it has a catchy icon,
but is then quickly uninstalled
will receive less
prominence than a title
that drives true user
engagement and retention.
We're also working
on several features
to improve the prominence and
conversion for premium games.
A lot of these are
really high quality,
but they have to overcome
this extra hurdle
of upfront payment.
The first of these features
we're announcing today,
and we're calling it
strikethrough pricing,
you can use
strikethrough pricing
to run a price promotion
on a premium app or game
in the Google Play Store.
Promotions drive awareness,
conversion, and a sense
of value for our users.
Here's how it works.
Any of you can log into
the Developer Console
today and set up a
promotion on your game.
You just tell us what
discount you want to apply,
when you want to apply
it, and we do the rest.
Users will see the original and
discounted price on the home
page, in the search results,
and in the app listing page.
In our early pilot
phase, developers
saw a lift in installs
ranging from 3x to 20x
when running a
promotion on their game.
Many of the developers
saw a sustained uplift
in performance, even after
the discount had ended.
So we're really excited
about the progress so far.
Now obviously, there
is a correlation
between the size of the discount
and the level of marketing
spend that you do, and
the size of the uplift.
But across the board, results
have been really encouraging,
and we'd like to see more of
you using this feature soon.
And throughout the year,
you'll see additional features
meant to drive more prominence
conversion for premium games
as we work to create a healthy
ecosystem of developers,
players, and pairs.
Another way we'll be
highlighting quality games
on Android is through
our new editorial pages
which are launching in Q2.
These pages allow Play
editors to showcase
magical, high-performing
Android games.
You can think of them
as a handcrafted page
built around a theme.
In this example, we've made
a page for roleplaying games.
Up top, we show an introduction
to the genre, followed
by a short list of titles
that have earned our love,
along with the reasons
why we picked them.
Now I'm going to
give you a sneak peek
into some features that
are a little bit earlier
in the development cycle.
I mentioned our shift to
reward deep engagement
over discarded downloads.
One way to do this is to
drive more qualified traffic
to our developers.
Today I might have to
download a 50 or 100 megabyte
game before really
figuring out what it does
and whether I'd like it.
And we'd like to help users
learn more about the game
before the download.
One way we're doing
this is exposing users
to more of your gameplay
earlier in the funnel
through inline videos.
These videos will show up on the
game's home page of the store.
And in addition to
the usual icons,
users will be able to browse
a set of videos for games
that we think they
will really like.
We're doing a similar test
for screenshots inline,
which will show up in the search
results and in the home page.
These features are designed
to simplify the search
and discovery experience
by giving users
a preview of what they're going
to experience without requiring
them to visit a
whole separate page.
And we think this will be
really helpful for the hundreds
of millions of
users who are coming
online with slower connections.
Now finally, we want
to help developers
like you drive repeat engagement
with your Android games.
Many of you have spent a lot
of money acquiring users.
And sometimes these users need
a little nudge to come back.
So we're going to be
testing LiveOps cards
in the store, which
give developers
a channel to drive awareness of
in-game activities and events.
These cards will show up on
the home pages in the store,
and also in the My Apps
section of the store,
where users are already coming
in to manage app updates.
That's a super early phase
of the project right now,
but we're sharing it
with you because we
think it's an important
part of driving engagement
and stickiness
with Android games.
So that's about it for me today.
I hope each of you
are a little bit more
convinced that Google is
serious about supporting
the quality of the
Android gaming experience
from our hardware to
the operating system,
from our Developer
Tools to the Play Store.
And we know that in order
to keep our users happy,
we depend on developers
like you to keep creating
incredible gaming experiences.
So I'd like to introduce Jamil
Moledina, our Games Strategic
Lead, who will announce a
set of exciting titles coming
to the platform.
[APPLAUSE]
JAMIL MOLEDINA: Thank you, Paul.
Hi, everyone.
It's a thrill to be
back on the GDC stage.
Between working on GDC
and coming to Google,
I converted my love of games
into actually making games,
and learned just how
hard this really is.
Yet this is a truly
extraordinary time
for mobile games.
And it's why I'm
excited to be here.
Supercell's "Clash Royale"
showed that you can finally
bring a synchronous
multiplayer game to mobile
and have it become a hit.
"Lineage 2" from
Netmarble and NCsoft
stormed our charts in Korea
as a full-fledged mobile MMO.
Plus, the biggest fan
communities in the world
are finding games made
for them on mobile too.
"Star Wars, Galaxy of
Heroes" from EA and Lucasfilm
let us collect
virtual action figures
and battle them like we
did with the plastic ones
when we were kids.
And mobile players were
rewarded that effort.
Nintendo came to mobile with
"Super Mario Run" and "Fire
Emblem Heroes," setting
records for preregistration
on Google Play.
And handcrafted
art and innovation
are also thriving and
finding an audience
on mobile, where
you can card-swipe
managing your kingdom
in "Reigns" from Nerial
and Devolver, or make
life-changing decisions
through the chaos of a
real world regime change,
as in "Revolution
1979" from iNK Studios.
All of this depth, community,
and diversity of play
was what we saw and supported
just in the past year.
What we're seeing coming up
doubles down on those trends.
And we're excited to bring
some of our game dev partners
onstage today to share
what they've got going on.
We'll highlight an
existing hits evolution,
share some big new games, and
close with some breakthrough
titles on new technology.
So let's get started.
Today, February 27, is a
very important birthday
in games in that
Pokemon is 21 years old.
[LAUGHTER]
Exactly.
"Pokemon Go," the hit augmented
reality game from Niantic,
driven by Google Maps
and Google Cloud,
got people across the
globe off the couch
and out catching Pokemon.
Fans were screaming for more.
And here to give us a
little of what we want
is Phil Keslin from Niantic.
[APPLAUSE]
PHIL KESLIN: Thanks
Jamil, and good morning.
I'm Phil Keslin, I'm
the CTO for Niantic.
Most people don't
know, or-- everybody
knows that we're the
"Pokemon Go" people.
But what most people don't
know is that we actually
started inside Google
about six years ago
as an independent organization
with a mission of creating
adventures on foot with others.
That mission was
set out to foster
exploration and discovery
in the real world.
The first app we launched
is called Field Trip.
It's a serendipitous
location-based discovery
application.
The idea was to
give you information
about the location that
you're currently standing in,
such as in the
financial district,
most people don't know that
buried beneath the buildings
are hundreds of ships that
were dragged into the landfill.
That title was launched in
2012, and we followed closely
with "Ingress," which is
our true location-based MMO.
It's a territory capture
game and in the four years
since its launch,
it's been downloaded
about 20 million times.
And it's still
going strong today.
Its user base is quite sticky.
Most of you may remember
in an April Fool's joke
at Google in 2014, the Google
Maps was littered with Pokemon.
And the success of
that April Fool's joke
sort of spawned an idea.
And that idea was,
build a real world
location-based MMO
based on Pokemon.
We approached the Pokemon
Company with that idea.
They in turn, played
"Ingress" a little bit
and discovered
that this actually
has a great deal of legs to it.
So together with
the Pokemon company,
we built and launched
the "Pokemon Go" game.
We started with a small
team of engineers.
There were nine
engineers on the team
that built that product, five
designers and two producers.
And as many of you are aware,
we were just a little bit
overwhelmed with the response.
It was about 50 times what
we originally anticipated.
And yeah, that summer
was quite a wild ride.
Actually, the 30 days,
with absolutely no pressure
at all except for
maybe the 9,000 people
in San Francisco who proposed
marching on our offices
if we couldn't get the servers
back up before the Market
Street crawl the Friday after we
launched in the United States.
Since we've launched, we've
stabilized everything.
We've added some
incremental changes.
But last week, we launched
the biggest update thus far.
And let's watch the video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
PHIL KESLIN: So
with this update,
we've added the second
generation of Pokemon,
those Pokemon from the "Gold"
and "Silver" series games.
Additionally, we changed
the counter-mechanics,
making capturing Pokemon
a bit more challenging.
And we've added avatar
customization to the title
as well.
Since we've launched,
we've had a little
over 650 million installs
of the application.
And our players are active too.
They've walked about
8.7 billion kilometers,
which is just shy of Pluto.
"Ingress" and "Pokemon
Go," as you might imagine,
they have some pretty
distinct technical challenges.
This is a single world MMO.
We're building a
planet-scale game
with demanding latency and
consistency requirements.
And it's capable of supporting
millions of simultaneous users,
and that is no easy task.
Luckily, we've had the support
of both the Google Cloud
and Google Play Store teams.
And having those 40 or so
faces during the launch
on the other side of the Hangout
was very, very reassuring
to the four engineers that were
trying to bring that server up.
When we started
Nianic, we wanted
to get people outside, off the
couch, playing games with one
another.
With "Ingress," and
especially "Pokemon Go,"
we saw this happen.
Of all that we achieved last
year, it was the smiles.
And the thing that put
the smiles on our faces
were the people getting outside,
seeing the teenagers running
around the neighborhood,
playing games with one another.
And that is what motivated us
to push through the tough times
and get a pretty fun
game into people's hands.
Both "Ingress" and "Pokemon
Go," they're not static titles.
We're going to continue
to evolve those over time.
And at launch, our game
play for "Pokemon Go"
was focused on the adventures
on foot part of our mission.
This year, we're going to
add more and more of the
with others portion of that by
adding social and collaborative
gameplay to the title as well.
And we at Niantic look
forward to sharing that
with you, along with maybe
one or two other surprises.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JAMIL MOLEDINA: Thank you, Phil.
"Pokemon Go" is
having a great ride.
And we're excited to
see the game continue
to evolve with these great
new characters and upcoming
features.
Now we'd like to share with
you a trio of brand new games
about to launch on Google Play.
Kabam is an established
partner on our store,
making hit games well-tuned
the mobile marketplace.
Recently, they've been showing
some of their console DNA
and love for all
genres of games.
Their latest game combines 3D
fighter, RPG, and base building
in a console quality game,
around a brand whose community
is ready to roll out.
Please join me in welcoming
Jeff Howell and Mike
McCartney from Kabam.
[APPLAUSE]
MIKE MCCARTNEY: Thanks Jamil.
We're really excited
to be here and show off
Kabam's next free-to-play AAA
quality game, "TRANSFORMERS,
Forged to Fight."
"Forged to Fight"
is the first game
to feature the entire history
of the Transformers franchise.
So whether you're a fan
of the classic generations
characters, characters from
the Transformers movies,
or even the Maximals and
Predacons from the Beast Wars
series, our game
has you covered,
featuring intense one-versus-one
combat, deep strategic RPG
systems, and engaging
social gameplay.
As commander, you'll
partner with Optimus Prime
to establish a
base and defend it
with a collection of your
favorite Transformers.
So let's dig into that
part of the game right now.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MIKE MCCARTNEY: So last
night while I was asleep,
my friend overseas
raided my base.
And I found out when I woke up,
and I was really aggravated,
and all I could think about
was exacting some revenge.
So why don't we go
and finish off the job
and take out his
boss and his beast?
JEFF HOWELL: So
for Transformers,
it was really important for
us that we push the limits
on visuals and really
change people's
expectations of what is
possible on a mobile platform.
To accomplish this feat, we had
to build a brand new rendering
engine from the ground
up we'd call Ember.
Ember combines
physically-based rendering
and a deferred lighting model
to do a full dynamically lit
environment, and really
brings our robots to life.
Devices like the Google
Pixel, like Mike is playing on
right now, have an incredible
amount of rendering horsepower.
And Ember can extract
all that power
to bring this console quality
level of graphics to mobile.
On top of just rendering,
we developed a brand new
GPU-based physics engine.
By using multiple
rendered targets
and keeping the physics
state in texture format,
we can calculate and simulate
collisions for over 50,000
particles, all in real time,
all rendered in beautiful HDR.
And we even can draw them
all in a single draw call.
Mike, for fun, let's show
the power of the Google Pixel
and turn on Ludicrous
Mode for our sparks.
MIKE MCCARTNEY: All
right, if you're sure.
Here we go.
JEFF HOWELL: All
right, it's time
to show what real
transformation is about.
Let's finish off Optimus Prime.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
MIKE MCCARTNEY: Without the
power of the Google Pixel,
these high fidelity graphics
and silky smooth performance
would not be possible.
Thanks to Google, my
revenge is complete.
"TRANSFORMERS, Forged to Fight"
is beta in select territories
right now.
And today we're announcing
for the first time
that the game will be available
globally on April 5, 2017.
Go pre-register on
Google Play now.
Thank you everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
JAMIL MOLEDINA: Thank you, guys.
You know, that is really
fun to play as well.
They've definitely cracked
input for high fidelity games.
Now, finding that balance
between classic game design
and mobile play can
be very complex.
The next game is from one of
the leaders in the AAA console
space.
And they've truly taken
this concept to heart.
What you're going to
see is a game made first
for mobile in
accessibility and design,
but for the gamer in all of
us, especially for those of us
who grew up in the '80s.
I'm very pleased to
introduce to this stage
Donald Mustard from Epic Games.
[APPLAUSE]
DONALD MUSTARD: Thanks, Jamil.
Hey everyone.
Thanks so much for
having us here today.
We could not be more excited
to be with you at GDC
to announce a brand
new game from Epic.
Powered, of course,
by Unreal Engine 4.
Now we all know Unreal Engine
is synonymous with making
AAA high fidelity experience
for all gaming platforms.
Its versatility combined
with the power devices
like the Google Pixel are what
allowed us to design and create
the game we're
about to show you.
I am so thrilled to
present "Battle Breakers."
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- "Battle Breakers!"
DONALD MUSTARD: All right,
so "Battle Breakers" was
born from us saying, what if
we took our love for zany '80s
Saturday morning cartoons
and combined that
with our obsession with
tactical turn-based RPGs?
And so, in my best
announcer voice,
your world was at peace
when monsters from space
attacked, trapping your
world and its heroes
in techno magic crystal.
So that's the setup, right?
All right.
So this game is all about
your heroes and your team.
So this is my team right now.
And there's over 250 heroes
in the game at launch.
So for this demo, I'm going to
augment my team a little bit
and I'm going to check out
Stormbringer She's awesome
because she has
this hurricane blade
attack that will be perfect
for what I'm about to show you.
So I'm going to
add her to my team,
and enter one of the
games over 600 levels.
I'm also going to add one of my
real world friends to the team,
because they have this
awesome character named Razor,
and she's amazing and
I want her on my team.
So all my characters are now
getting added into the level.
Let me tell you about
how the game works.
So the game is based on these
very poppable crystal tiles
that you pop and break
to find different things.
You can find everything
from gold and treasure
to crafting materials,
and all sorts
of different kinds of loot.
You'll also find enemies.
And you need to use your
heroes and your team
to take these guys out.
We use a pretty dynamic
rock-paper-scissors system,
right?
So red is best at green,
green is best at blue,
and so on and so forth.
Each hero also has a really
unique, special ability
like this one that
clears the board
and lets me move
to the next stage.
All right, so that's
a big-looking crystal
which probably means
boss fight, right?
So the Unholy
Summoner is a big bad
that my team needs to take out.
But my guys look awesome,
we can handle this.
I'm going to do my
favorite feature now,
which I'm going to
accelerate the game's speed
and put it into auto mode.
So now I can just sit back and
watch the beautiful graphics
as my team takes this guy out.
Now this game is
actually completely 3D.
So we're using Unreal to
layer on all this cool 2D
art over a 3D
world, which allows
us to get these very unique
effects and transitions
that you're seeing.
All right, the boss is
dead, let's collect our loot
and get out of here.
So I'm now able to unlock
a permanent upgrade stat
and open up all my loot.
Awesomely, I was able
to get a hero crystal.
So now let's open that
and see what we find.
So all the heroes are
trapped in these crystals.
And I'm going to pop it
open and see what we get,
which is Kaldin.
This is awesome, this is
one of the most rare heroes
in the game.
And he's awesome
because he can transform
into an awesome dragon warrior.
- "Battle Breakers!"
[END PLAYBACK]
DONALD MUSTARD: All right,
that's "Battle Breakers."
So at Epic, we
love playing games,
and we love the technology
that makes games.
But most of all, we
love making games.
And we love making them for
players all over this world.
And I cannot wait for you to
get this game in your hands.
"Battle Breakers" is available
worldwide very, very soon.
But you can actually
pre-register for the game
starting right now.
And all those who
pre-register will
receive exclusive and
special dark beast man
when the game launches.
So go check it all out
at battlebreakers.com.
Thanks so much.
[APPLAUSE]
JAMIL MOLEDINA: That was
awesome Donald, thank you.
Thank you for
sharing that with us.
Now serious question, who's
planning to play hooky from GDC
and go see "Lego
Batman" instead?
Show of hands.
Come on, don't be shy.
You've had enough of
this show already.
[LAUGHTER]
I have to admit doing something
similar at Casual Connect
when "The Dark Knight
Rises" came out.
I bring this up to point out
how comic book heroes are really
front and center in the
public consciousness.
In film, television, and of
course games, players on the go
want to be Batman as much as
the console player in the living
room.
To help bring that wish to life
our friends at DC and Warner
Brothers.
Let's welcome Erin Piepergerdes
from Warner Brothers
NetherRealm Studios.
[APPLAUSE]
ERIN PIEPERGERDES:
Thank you Jamil.
You guys, I couldn't be more
excited to be here today
to give you a quick
look at "Injustice 2."
Let's dive right into the
action here so you guys
can see what I'm talking about.
This is of course the sequel
to "Injustice, Gods Among Us."
And one of the
things you guys are
going to see when we
get into the action
here is the hyper-realistic
level of detail
that we've been able to achieve.
Well, let's take a look.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
ERIN PIEPERGERDES: Now as we
start the fight here-- again,
notice the level of
detail that I mentioned.
This is perfectly suited to
these iconic DC characters
like Batman and Harley Quinn.
So how did we achieve such
a visually stunning game?
I know there's a lot of
developers in the audience
today, so we wanted to give
you a little bit of insight
into our process.
Unreal Engine 4 natively
provides [INAUDIBLE]
profiles, which we can use
to adjust graphic settings
like shadow, resolution, and
bloom on a per-device basis.
Now we've actually hosted
this on online backend,
so we can make real
time adjustments.
All of this is very
useful when you
have a tendency to design
some pretty over-the-top moves
like this.
Superman is not messing around.
Now "Injustice 2" is going to
be a very full-featured game
when it comes out.
There's a lot of
variety of modes
that the players can
experience and a lot of things
they can do in this game.
One of the things that we want
to actually highlight today
is what we're calling
our gear system.
So we'll take a look
at this in action.
So gear, you guys can think of
as customizable costume pieces
that you collect as
you play the game
and equip to your characters.
Here we're looking at the
base level version of Batman.
Notice below him he's
got his pieces of gear.
As you collect these and
equip them to your character,
not only does it change
the visual appearance,
but it also changes how
the character plays.
It changes his base
stats and abilities.
So here we've added all
five pieces, and notice
again a very different version
of the evolved predator Batman
now.
So you see the
visual difference.
But there are also gameplay
implications here as well.
So let's take a look at
a couple other examples.
This time we'll take a
look at Wonder Woman.
So here, the base
version of Wonder Woman.
And again, as you play the game
you collect the gear pieces.
You've got the headpiece
the chestpiece,
the arms, legs, and her
shield, her accessory.
Once you've got them all,
you can achieve set bonuses,
different stats, really
upgrading and making
this character much,
much more powerful.
And finally making his
debut here at GDC of course
is Scarecrow.
The idea here is the same.
You're going to collect
all your gear and equip it,
and this time you have a very
different-looking Scarecrow.
Our artists had a lot of fun
making up different looks
for these iconic characters.
Now let's see this in action.
We're going to take a quick look
at a second fight, this time
with the evolved versions
of these characters
you'll see they're much more
powerful than what we just saw.
Now
the visuals are
not the only thing
that got an upgrade
in "Injustice 2."
Combat is also much
deeper this time around.
You'll see you can do things
like low attacks, high attacks.
You can actually dash back
away from your opponent
and throw projectiles.
And with time and
practice, players
can actually string these
different moves together
to form some pretty cool combos.
Now of course, in addition
to the basic attacks,
all the characters
also have special moves
that they can utilize
with really cool custom
animations, effects.
And again as they
fight back and forth,
notice that detail we've
been able to achieve,
as I mentioned.
Now you guys want to see one
more supermove before we go?
All right, making its debut
here at GDC for the first time,
this is Scarecrow's supermove.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
ERIN PIEPERGERDES: "Injustice
2" is the culmination
of a lot of very talented
people's efforts back
in Chicago.
We couldn't be more excited to
be bringing this game to you.
Look for it to launch
worldwide in May
and you can pre-register
starting today.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
JAMIL MOLEDINA: That's
just incredible.
And it's the same
game that's launching
on console at the same time.
Congratulations.
At Google Play, we're
proud of these games that
respect and deliver
for the communities
that love these brands.
Visit the Play Store
right now as we're
doing a special
update for GDC where
you can pre-register the
three titles you've just seen.
Another important
part of Android is VR.
Just a few months ago,
we launched Daydream,
with a portfolio that
delivers low friction
VR with appealing, accessible,
and engaging experiences.
To continue growing
the Daydream platform,
we recently announced
partnerships with Huawei, Asus,
and ZTE for new Daydream-ready
phones and headsets,
with many more
partners coming soon.
Today we'd like to announce
two new Daydream games
that help show that momentum.
First up is a great
partner of ours
and supporter of innovation
on multiple platforms.
From Ubisoft Montpellier,
please welcome
Loic Gounon and Fred Mizac.
[APPLAUSE]
LOIC GOUNON: Thanks Jamil.
Hello everyone.
Ubisoft, as you know, has
always been among the first
when it comes to
innovative platforms.
And we are proud
today to showcase
what Daydream is capable of by
bringing the kind of emotions
to our players.
We at Ubisoft Montpellier
are excited to present to you
a funny and immersive experience
from the original creators
of the "Raving Rabbids."
This new game is called
"Virtual Rabbids, The Big Plan."
And now let's take
a look at the game.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
LOIC GOUNON: In this experience
you see on the screen,
you will use the
remote as a chameleon
and use its tongue
to catch objects.
But the rabbit is going
to get in your way.
And during an
operation, you'll have
to tell the rabbits
by shaking your head
if you want the object
back in your body or not.
So you probably want
to keep your heart.
[END PLAYBACK]
LOIC GOUNON: That's
a nice image.
So for the very
first time player,
we'll be interacting
directly with the rabbits.
You can get up closer
to them than ever before
and your action will
have an impact on what's
going on around you, creating
hilarious situations.
FRED MIZAC: Working with
Google on the Daydream platform
is great because it allows us
to deliver high quality games
in a mobile VR environment.
Daydream also brings a
great way to interact
with the virtual world
thanks to the controller.
It is light, it
is simple to use,
and brings lots of
new gameplay ideas.
We are eager to have you try
out our game at Google Daydream
booth starting Wednesday.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JAMIL MOLEDINA: Thank you guys.
That was a great example of
interacting with characters
made much more real in VR.
Now a lot of you know that
indies are very near and dear
to our hearts.
They risk everything for
innovation and expression,
and bring a richer
diversity of delight
to everyone on their
platform of choice.
We work hard to make
sure that indies have
a home on Google Play, too.
Last year on this stage, we
announced the Indie Corner.
This dedicated page
on the Play Store
highlights fresh new launches,
as well as proven indie
masterpieces.
We're excited to see
the program continue
to grow after featuring
over 250 games
and driving millions of
installs in its first year.
And we were just getting
started with that.
Since then, we've
tested new ways
to discover and support indies
by hosting our first indie game
festivals and contests for
developers across the world--
in Seoul, San Francisco,
and two weeks ago in London.
Keep your eyes open
for more efforts
like these throughout the year.
Now we're committed
to helping indies grow
on Android and Google Play.
The dedication and passion
you have is incredible.
And we thank you
for your commitment.
Given this instinct to
innovate, indies are frequently
the first to experiment
and find new ways to bring
new ideas to new platforms.
And they're willing to open
perspectives through empathy.
It's then with a
special pleasure
to share and reveal a game that
hits all of our hot buttons,
including social
and persistence.
From our friends at
Spry Fox, please join me
in welcoming Daniel Cook.
[APPLAUSE]
DANIEL COOK: Hello everyone.
So Spry Fox has been making
little tiny games for years.
"Triple Town," "Alphabear,"
"Realm of the Mad God,"
"Bushido Bear."
Last June we started thinking
about our very first VR game.
We had a couple of goals.
First, we wanted to build a
home for the Spry Fox bears.
Millions of people have
played these characters,
and they absolutely adore them.
But we've never
really had a chance
to build out the world
in which they live.
Second, and probably
more importantly,
to be quite honest,
is we wanted to build
something that was positive,
something that we could maybe
counteract a lot of the really
horrendous negativity that's
been swirling around
the world lately.
So we started dreaming.
What if we could build
a nice gaming community?
What if we could
make a game where
everyone is encouraged to
be helpful, friendly and
inclusive?
So we've been working on
a big, beautiful game that
does just that.
We call it "Beartopia."
"Beartopia" is an
honest-to-goodness game.
Many VR experiences end up
being these sort of short demos.
In "Beartopia," you play in
this rich, persistent world, one
that you can come back
to every single day.
"Beartopia" is multiplayer.
Everyone lives together
in this amazing village.
And you'll meet other players
and you'll build friendships.
And finally, "Beartopia"
is completely co-operative.
It is our firm belief
that every single game
player is an immigrant
into the worlds we build.
And we have a duty
as creators to ensure
that our virtual communities
bring out the best in people.
In "Beartopia,"
all the players are
immigrants to this
lovely seaside village,
coming there for the first time.
And in this little
utopia, we've set it
up so that everyone
can work together.
Because we know that when we
mix different people from all
walks of life, we build strong,
exciting, vibrant communities.
So "Beartopia" is
something really special,
and we really can't wait
to share it with you.
Here is a very brief teaser.
Thank you.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
JAMIL MOLEDINA: Thank you Dank.
As an immigrant myself,
I love that you've
made this game
that can put anyone
in the shoes of an outsider
coming to your country.
Thank you for making this game.
And that's just a
glimpse into what's
coming to Daydream
and Google Play.
Games are important to Google.
That's why we're here at the
Game Developers Conference.
We understand that engagement,
discovery, and high fidelity
performance are important,
which inspires the advancements
Paul shared earlier.
We're thrilled to see
game developers integrate
these trends into
their games on Android.
And Android through Google Play
is already the world's largest
platform for games.
We're working to
make sure it's also
the best platform for games.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]